It was a UUID v1 sandwich attack or IDOR.
So that's great.
The sandwich attack.
That's what it was.
I should have remembered.
Yeah.
Your specialty.
Hey everyone.
So this week we've got a different type of episode.
We had a cancellation on the pod and I had the opportunity to do an episode that I was
really excited about for a really long time, which is having my wife Mariah on the podcast.
Now, if you've listened to critical thinking for any period of time, you know how much I
mentioned her and how much of an inspiration and help she's been to me and my bug bounty
career.
So I wanted to take some time to interview her, her experiences at the live hacking event,
her experiences with the highs and lows of bug bounty as I crashed to the depths of despair
over a dupe or I'm on top of the world after I find a crit.
So we did a little interview with her and I think she's really amazing.
I think you guys will too.
And hopefully you'll be able to take some tidbits out from our conversation and apply them to
your own relationships and let bug bounty not be a strainer in your relationship, but something
that amplifies it and makes it more enjoyable.
So with that, I hope you guys enjoy this episode.
All righty, my love, we are recording and everyone today, we have a special episode.
We had a cancellation on the pod, so we had an opportunity to bring on an episode that I've
really been looking forward to doing for a long time, which is an episode with my wife,
Mariah.
Hi everyone.
I'm Mariah.
So let's go ahead and look at the episode plan that I've got in place here.
The next thing up that I wanted to do was I've got some bug bounty questions for you
as a bug bounty wife.
So let me elaborate a little bit on what I was thinking for this episode.
So you guys know if you've listened to the podcast for any period of time that I talk
about Mariah a lot on the episodes.
And yeah, she's just been a really great support and encouragement to me throughout my bug bounty
journey.
So I thought we could talk a little bit about that and about how to encourage your hacker
and how to, I guess, be an awesome bug bounty wife or girlfriend.
And then I also wanted to take this little segment in the beginning to ask you some hacking questions
and see how much over the years you've absorbed.
Does that sound good?
I have been to more live hacking events than I can count, more than probably most of you
will ever go to.
And I've listened to a lot of show and tells and have heard this one talk quite a lot about
a lot of things.
So I'm optimistic that you'll give me some questions I might be able to answer.
All right.
I think you'll do great.
So let's go ahead and start it out.
Okay.
First question.
What are the two primary HTTP proxy softwares?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
HTTP proxy softwares.
So Burp and Kaido.
Burp and Kaido.
That's right.
Correct.
Ding, ding, ding.
One point Mariah.
Easy.
That's not even a technical question.
Yeah.
Okay.
They're coming.
Don't worry.
Hmm.
I'm not going to go down the list in order.
What are the happy bug bounty report states?
Like what are the on hacker one?
Is happy an acronym?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's not an acronym.
What are the, what are the states of a report on hacker one that, uh, triage?
Is that what you're talking about?
Yeah.
Triaged is one.
What, what, what are some of the other ones?
Do you know any of the other ones?
Triaged only.
Uh, I got a dupe.
That's not a happy state.
That's not a happy one.
Just that good ones.
Yeah.
Can you give me any, well, I've got, triaged and paid, like, triaged and paid.
Paid is not a state.
Okay.
So triaged.
Resolved is the state.
Resolved.
There you go.
Very nice, Mariah.
Um, the, the other one is pending program review.
That's like the program needs to go.
So it's been triaged by the company and.
By hacker one.
And then the company needs to go in and review it.
Pending program review.
Right.
I was trying to be more like program agnostic.
Okay.
Sure.
One's not the only one that like triages.
That's true.
Um, okay.
So what about the sad bug bounty states?
You said one of them.
Dupe for sure.
Uh, what's the one?
The not applicable one.
Hmm.
Not applicable.
Good.
Is that applicable?
Is that the right word?
Not applicable yet.
Ah!
Um, out of scope.
Out of scope.
Yep.
Uh, that's not, that's not a state.
That's not a state.
But it is a, a, uh, you know, a delegation.
Did they ever just send you a thumbs down and.
Yeah.
There's one that starts with an I that, that I think you know.
I'm sure I do.
I didn't hear you say it.
Inconceivable.
In, inconceivable?
That's actually when it's critical.
Can I give you an I?
Inconceivable.
Informative.
Yeah.
So like it sort of worked, but it doesn't really do anything.
Yeah, exactly.
Um, all right, let's see.
In your estimation, how much time does it normally take for a hacker to find a bug on a new scope?
For a hacker to find a bug.
I'm sure it depends.
It's very, it's very, it does, it does.
That's.
Well, we'll try to generalize it.
We'll say for you, in my estimation for you.
Okay.
It takes.
About a week to find.
15 bugs.
A week to find 15 bugs.
Holy crap.
So you spend like.
Three days not finding any bugs.
Whining about it.
And then on day four, he founds like seven.
And he's like, oh, nevermind.
And then the rest of the week, he just finds them steady from there.
Accurate.
Yeah, I think, I think that first part with three days and no bugs and then the tidal wave.
I think that's very accurate.
Okay.
Um, I'm not sure if I've talked to you about this level of nuance, but let me ask you this.
So, you know, there's CVSS, right?
Yeah.
That's how we, we re rate the vulnerabilities.
Oh, I know.
Yes.
Um, there's a metric in CVSS called privilege required.
Okay.
And the values for that metric are none low and high.
Right.
So if you find a bug on, it's easy on an application that is self sign up, right?
You can go in and sign up.
Nobody has to approve anything, anything like that.
What is the value for the privilege required metric?
If you have to be, if you have to sign up, it should be low.
Is it no privilege?
No, Mariah.
No.
You have committed the fatal error.
Um, it's none.
It's none.
Yeah.
Well, we like to think it's none.
For any of you program managers listening out there, this is not an endorsement.
Just because she says that doesn't mean I'm going to accept it.
Okay.
You have to be a user.
That means it's listed up by definition.
Yeah.
But, but privilege required.
So the don't, don't give you that look.
Don't give you that look.
I'm not sure.
But, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but,
but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but,
the attack starts from where, you know, you can define from where the attack starts.
So you can actually make a, wait, stop.
I can explain this totally fine to anyone else.
I can explain this.
Let me see what else we got here.
What I kind of already covered this, but what is CVSS?
Do you know what CVSS is?
Let me see if I can.
You don't have to give me the acronym.
No, I kind of want to know the acronym because CVS is like the scoring system of whether or
not something is, you know, from informative to critical.
And I'm actually going to look it up.
I think it's common vulnerability scoring system.
Yeah, it is.
Scoring system.
So you get half, full half points for that.
Full half points.
Oh, thank you for your generosity.
You're welcome.
So, all right, cool.
And then we've got it.
We've got another technical one and then we'll, oh, and then we'll do a non-technical one.
What is an XSS?
XSS is cross-eyed scripting.
Good.
Can you explain what it is?
Not as well as an eye door.
Eye door is my favorite.
Yeah.
Cross-eyed scripting is, so you've got like the page.
Right.
And you.
On the right track.
You've got a web page.
You can sort of like paste your own code over that web page.
So if you send someone a link, you can make them traverse through your malicious code to
the web page and have like both.
Like a pack.
It's like a package deal.
That is somewhat accurate.
Yeah, exactly.
So you've got your malicious page.
Yeah.
And then how does the package deal?
Well, they go through your link.
Okay.
Yes, exactly.
Exactly.
They go through the link on our attacker page.
And then it's still like the website's link.
Yes.
It's their website's link.
Instead of like badguy.rinerader.com.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
I need to register that right now.
I need to put that DNS entry in.
Just before it airs.
Badguy.rinerader.com.
And that is where I'm going to host all of my POCs from now on.
Yeah.
So then you're right.
So they click our malicious link that was on our website.
And then what happens to their website?
Sucks up the bad website.
Yeah.
So then you're right.
So they click our malicious link that was on our website.
And then what happens to their website?
Sucks up the bad website.
Yeah.
So they're right.
So they click our malicious link that was on our website.
Sucks up the bad website.
It sucks up the bad website.
And then they can only interact with the bad good website.
Yeah.
I mean, that's pretty accurate.
Because what you're doing is you're running code on their website.
Right?
Yeah.
Is that what you meant to say?
But it's not.
You haven't actually changed the website.
That's right.
It's only in the victim's browser, right?
Other people aren't seeing it.
Yeah.
That's accurate.
Very good.
Very good, sweetheart.
You rocked it.
What is a good range for low, medium, high and crit bounties?
Good bounty range for each thing?
Yeah.
Low should be at least 8k.
What?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Well, you said I answered too, like, not pro hacker on the other ones.
No, no, no.
You're doing great.
You are doing perfectly.
Um, okay.
So we're talking about like, what is, what would I expect to see?
Not what is like, would be good.
Cause like, would be good is probably higher in general.
Yes.
What is like, maybe a, if you look at a program, you're like, oh, that's pretty good bounty table.
When I look at my programs, what I'm looking for is like, at least 1k for lows.
1k for lows.
Okay.
Great.
Like out of the hundreds, I feel like it's pretty good.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um, mediums around 5k.
I'm pretty sure I've heard you say.
Okay.
You're doing, you're doing great.
You're right on the money at this point.
Highs.
I guess I don't, it varies a lot for programs or programs between a medium and a high, right?
It does.
Yes.
So like 8k to 10k.
Okay.
10k.
Yeah.
10k can be some crits too.
So I'm sure there's like a, there are definitely programs that pay 10k crits.
And I, I personally kind of like a really wide range for crits.
Like 10k does feel like a crit payout to me, but also like 30k.
Would be a hundred K crit payouts.
Like some of these companies should definitely be paying a hundred K for it.
Yeah.
Shopify has, I think like 25 or maybe it's 50 to 200 K for crits.
Um, and.
So 50 is their lowest crit.
You may not ever get them to pay it because of the way that their vulnerability rating system
works.
But, um, the fact that it does exist and I have seen them pay it a couple of times.
So yeah, that's a pretty big range.
So you like the bigger ranges on the crits?
You know, I do.
I'd rather be paid as a hacker, right?
I'd rather be paid out 10k for a crit than never be paid out 50k for a crit.
Yeah, absolutely.
Right.
Yeah.
That's just my personal.
That's I agree.
I think that's a great, um, I think that's a great approach.
All right.
So that's all I had for my questions.
You did very well.
I'm going to give you a little round of applause here.
Thank you.
Those are like very, very gettable.
Yeah.
Well, um, okay.
So now I've got a couple of sections here in the doc that we can go over.
Um, I'm really personally curious and hopefully, um, I won't put you on the spot too much to
hear about your memories from the live hacking events and the show and tells.
Oh my gosh.
Because I know you've got a couple that you really like.
Wait, the show and tells specifically?
Or just like story time?
Ideally the show and tells.
Cause you know, it's like a, it's like a hacking podcast, you know, like we'd like
to tell them about hacking stories.
Um, but also, uh, Mariah just, just for, for reference, Mariah has a lot better memory
than I do.
Um, and so when we talk about like our history of our relationship and like, uh, uh, just
in general, um, she has a better recollection of, of what's actually happened normally.
So I was thinking we could also go and cover a little history of our, our relationship plus
bug bounty.
Yeah.
Um, so I think one of the classics, can we talk about like what, who was like sponsoring
event?
Like who was hosting the event at all of these ones or no?
I would recommend not.
Yeah.
Um, yeah.
Cause sometimes it's most of the time it's not really relevant to like the general feel of
a life hacking event, but sometimes it's has been relevant.
Yeah.
For good, better for worse.
Right.
No, good, good question, sweetie.
Good question.
Um, so let's talk a little bit about the first live hacking event in the story from your perspective,
because, um, my first live hacking event was, uh, I want to say it was H1 3 1 3 or something
like that in Washington DC, which is close to where I live.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is not 2015.
Sorry.
No, my bad math.
2018?
2017.
Yeah.
I did the wrong.
2017, I think.
Um, and yeah, uh, it's an interesting story of how I got into that event and I've told that,
that story before on the podcast.
So I kind of want to hear Mariah's take on the story.
Do you remember?
Yeah.
I remember a lot about it.
Sorry.
I hyped you up.
I was like, her memory is amazing.
And then you're like, I have no idea what you're talking about.
I have at least 300 details about this event.
I'll pare it down for the audience.
Um, at that point in time, we were like massively in college debt, still in college.
No, this is the relevant part for me.
We just started out.
Okay.
No, that's good.
Cause like, we were like flexible money now, right?
Yeah.
At this point in time, we did not have flexible money.
We had negative flexible money.
And Justin, when he was like in high school and I knew I hadn't met him in high school,
he was in high school.
When he was younger, I knew he had like done some like hacking stuff.
Right.
But then he sort of heard about bug bounty and then sort of started it like very loosely while
we were like in college and moving around and like very had a lot going on.
But he was like doing this for fun sometimes.
And I know he had some of the skill set beforehand.
Um, we got married in end of junior year of college, just for, for the record, you know,
the summer we were forcing you.
I guess most of the time that I knew about bug bounty, I think we were already in a serious
relationship or married.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Um, so he got invited from this.
From this friend to go to DC, which is not, was not, it's not far from where we live or lived and do this thing.
And I feel like in college is such a good time to like do a ton of things you haven't done.
Like I went to college.
I went to like tons of, I went to conferences of different types.
I like tried different things.
I would try like 30 different clubs at my school.
Like I was definitely in a habit of like trying multiple clubs.
Like, yeah.
Nice.
I feel like we were in a really good habit of trying things that we didn't already like do.
Right.
Like that's college is an awesome time to do so many things you've never done.
So he got invited to go to this conference is sort of how it was pitched, which live hanging events are not at all like a conference.
Yeah.
Um, in DC.
And he was like, Oh, it's far.
And like, we already have a lot to do.
And I don't know.
And I was like, Justin, so stupid.
You can drive to DC in a day and come back and like meet people and like do something you haven't done.
It was last minute too.
It was last minute.
It was like the next day.
Yeah, it was.
It was like, yeah, it was super last minute.
And the friend that invited you also, you know, wasn't a friend we hang out with all the time.
So, you know, it wasn't like to see your friend that you were going to go.
Right.
But yeah, I was like, you, you're doing this.
You're like having fun doing it.
And he had just made some money off of doing it.
Yeah.
Like that week or the week before something like super recent.
I think I landed like one of my first bounties.
It was like probably my third or fourth, but it was 20, $2,500, which was like a good chunk.
A really impactful amount of money at that point in time, like a very noticeable, like, wow, you just like sat on your computer for part of a weekend and like made a good chunk of money that we can really use for our lives.
Yeah.
So it was like worth noticing.
And yeah, I was like, yeah, definitely go.
And then I think, I don't even think I was going to go with you in the first draft.
And then because you were a plus one plus one.
So you didn't know you could bring someone.
And then I just ended up coming or did you just end up coming?
Yeah.
You just ended up coming anyway.
And we were like, I don't think we did.
Because it was like, it was like, we were our, the person that invited us was a plus one.
And then I was the plus one of the plus one.
And then you were my plus one.
Yeah.
And you were like, I don't know that you can come.
And I was like, I don't know that I can come.
I had like a paper to write and stuff.
I had a lot of writing to do in school.
Oh, you were working.
I was like, yeah, I was working on home.
I was like drowning in homework.
I couldn't have gone if I didn't do more.
So yeah, I showed up with my laptop and I was like doing high writing in a corner.
And I don't know if they got any pictures of you, but it's really funny because, you know, Mariah will come to most of the live hacking events, which we'll cover in a bit.
But and like she is, I think she's had a whole page dedicated to her face in the HackerOne Hacker Report of her like in their defense, like, you know, most of the time when she's on her computer at these live hacking events, she'll be just doing something else.
But this time you were actually doing like, was it like a training?
They did like a clinic.
It was like a women and hacking 101 or something.
I think it was.
It was like in the middle of a live hacking event.
It's kind of a strange setup for it.
But yeah, they were like, it was like, let's install burp on your computer.
And then like, here's just some sandboxes and stuff to like click around in and hack and like no more instruction.
It was just like hack this.
And you're like, okay, well, thanks for installing burp, I guess.
But that was like the extent of the trainings.
It was really cool, though, because she was wearing glasses at the time.
She since got LASIK, but she was wearing glasses and like the shot was over the computer and you can kind of see this the computer screen like sort of reflecting in her glasses at the time.
So it was it was pretty.
Let's jump ahead to the event because we've been on the story already.
Go ahead.
So anyway, he ends up choosing to go to the event as a plus plus plus.
And then I ended up going along and being like, worst they can do is say no.
And we've driven just a couple hours to DC and he's going to go in anyway.
But they let me in and they let me just click on my computer in a corner and eat food and stuff, which is great.
And then meet people.
I met a lot of people.
I met a lot of the OG staff at that point.
Um, and some hackers.
I remember meeting John Botterini.
Yeah, John Botterini.
Classic, classic Botterini.
I mean, I have a lot of different names for a lot of the hackers that are not their names.
Not mean ones, but like Bottle Tot is what I usually call them.
Bottle Tot.
Because it's just easier to say than Botterini.
I'm sorry, John.
I'm so sorry, dude.
It is what happens, though.
What other names do you have for other hackers?
There's so many hacker names.
Um, we have-
There's Big Sam and Little Sam.
Big Sam, Little Sam.
We're not going to tell you which ones are which.
Both of them have been on the podcast, though.
It has nothing to do with sizes.
It's like a vibe, you know?
Yeah.
Size, a person's size is all about their vibe.
Um, we have Little Jack.
He's not around too much anymore.
Little Jack isn't around anymore.
Um, a lot of people, I actually know their hacker names and hacker handles.
Yeah.
Real names or their hacker handles, and I use both or either of them.
I'm trying to think if I have any more like out of left field names.
I can't think of any off the top of my head.
Okay.
So what other memories do you have from that original event?
Um, I remember the show and tell specifically at that one.
Cause I've been to a lot of life hacking events and seen the show and tells and like not remembered a lot of it.
But I remember like, cause Justin was, wasn't Franz at that event?
Franz was at that event.
I remember Justin was like crazy about Franz.
He was like, this is the super, super good hacker from Sweden.
I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, just like Justin just gonna like talk to him.
We're like in this like very small venue.
She literally made me go talk to him.
Like he had found some, I think this was like, I want to ask about this bug.
He had found this crazy bug.
I think it was a supply chain related bug, um, at the time.
And that was like, not anything.
Like nobody was doing that at the time.
And, uh, and I was like, I don't understand how this works.
I need to go figure out how this works.
And, and, but I was like, I can't really go up and talk to him.
So stupid.
I was like, this guy could literally just be a Joe off the street.
Like he's only famous to you.
I'm sure he's famous for many people, but like, we're like in a very intimate setting.
Like some of the venues are very small venue.
Some of the venues are very closed off, right?
Like lots of closable doors.
And I know that that makes, I think intentionally, right?
Some of the hackers less accessible, they would just want to focus and work.
And I think that's totally fine to respect that there wasn't closed off spaces.
It was like a very open floor plan.
And so I was like, Justin, we're in like this very small, this is not a conference for one.
We arrived and like, we're very sure it was not a conference.
Right.
We're like in a very intimate setting.
Like just go say, if you're here, then you can go say hi.
Like this is not like a, it's not that kind of thing.
So he talked to him and that was cool for him.
And I got to talk to some random hackers.
And I figured out Franz is a, is a person.
Yeah.
Crazy.
And he's not like some hacking God.
That's like a takeaway though.
I think that's like, if you have a live hacking event for the first time or the 10th time or whatever, and you're like afraid to meet people, just go talk to them.
And like, if they're jerks, that's on them.
You know, some people are jerks.
That's just how people are.
But like, most people are very open and like people, because I feel like that's a pretty easy default to assume.
Like if you are at the event, you can have a conversation with people at the event.
So I do.
I go to a lot of events.
I have conversations with lots of people.
I don't.
Yeah.
I certainly haven't earned my way to the event.
You definitely have some, some like good friendships with some top hackers and their, and their girlfriends too, which is great.
And so, all right.
So that's, that's the DC story.
Oh, do you remember anything from the show and tells?
Yeah.
Like one of the first show and tells I ever saw was, um, enties.
And it was like super memorable, like a really interesting guy.
I don't remember like meeting him or having conversations with him, but like he got up there and it's like a great presenter.
And he played this like video song that, um, about hacking.
And Justin has told me it's, it's Ruby's Ruby.
Yeah.
Ruby.
And I was like, what is happening?
There's like a whole subculture of like, hack music.
Like what is, what is this?
And then his presentation was just really good.
I couldn't tell you what it does.
I've seen like tons of good presentations and memorable things since then.
I like, um, Sam Curry's null boys.
Oh, null boys.
He put a lot of null boys into a class and it kept giving him information back.
That's right.
That's, that's an accurate.
I mean, that's pretty much the whole presentation.
That's how I remember.
The whole bug was like, he put in a null boys and then somehow that null bite was getting,
uh, filled with just random pieces of memory from the server.
And so he could just leak massive chunks of memory from the server.
Um, that's a good, that's a good memory.
I mean, some of these presentations are really memorable.
They are.
That's not on me.
That's, I love that.
Yeah.
They did, they did a good job.
Zero opsec on this guy.
Oh, zero.
That's donut.
That was donut.
Yeah.
Sorry.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
It's fine.
Uh, that was a, it doesn't matter.
Someone gave him like part of their social security number, part of it to test, uh, to
see if he could get the rest of it.
But social security numbers are already not that long.
Right.
So this person gives him part of a social security number and in the presentation, he
got zero opsec on that guy.
Yeah.
That was hilarious moment.
That was so good.
I loved that.
But don't, I got it.
That's why he's doing Chantel.
Yeah.
It worked and he did get more social security numbers than just that guy with zero opsec.
But yeah.
Yeah.
That was, that was lovely.
That was, that was a great Chantel.
What other, do you have any other ones off the top of your head?
I'm trying to think.
I love all of random deductions Chantels.
Yeah.
Especially the LA event last year was phenomenal.
Um, there have been some poems.
Oh my gosh.
There have been poems.
Archangel and crew have done some like.
Raps slash poems.
Limerick.
One of them was like Dr. Seuss.
It was, you're right.
Um, I'm sure I remember more.
I've, I know I've learned content from a lot of them.
Yeah.
Some of them just start sounding kind of the same.
Do you remember?
So that, that first event, do you remember what bug Inti was presenting on at all?
Do you remember any of the details about the bug?
Or like the song that he played?
I, I usually remember the song.
I'm having trouble right now.
Just a second.
We'll, we'll link the song in the description.
It's like, I hope it's still up.
I gotta go track it down.
But, uh, I can't remember right now.
It's a, it's, um, content injection song.
Do you remember that?
There's a content injection bug on your.
I just kept remembering it kept stopping at the your.
Yeah.
Content injection bug on your.
And it like, so you don't really, I don't remember a lot of the bug cause that's the content
I got.
I was like, where's the content injection?
Oh, so such a good, such a good memory.
Um, all right.
Solid.
Good.
Oh, you know what?
Another really good one was, I think it was, um, I think it was, um, I think it was
a good memory.
Um, all right.
Solid.
Good.
Oh, you know what?
Another really good one was, I think it was, um, I think it was a good memory.
Um, all right.
Solid.
Good.
And it was a really good one was I think it was, um, Oh, XACB and Fisher.
Yeah.
They got a massive.
Was that the one where they, um, just changed the, just like, um, default password or set email
or something like that.
Yeah.
You could just change.
You could just, instead of like, trying to hack someone's password, they just said,
just kidding.
Send my password or a set token to my email.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
That's right.
I like the ones that are just like that, that are like so stupid.
Yeah.
Like you could, yeah.
I mean, you didn't even need burp for that one.
Like, you literally could just type it in.
Wait a second.
Don't send it to this email.
Send every password or set to my email.
That was crazy.
That was, that's, that's a good, a good memory.
That was, I think that was one of the first bugs that I'd seen that got, I don't know
if we can say how much it got paid out, but it was like a very large amount.
And it was very staggering at the time.
Yeah.
So, yeah, I agree.
That was, that was a great one too.
Um, so let's see, let's, let's skip forward a little bit.
Um, so, you know, we did that first event and then you and I kind of went to a couple events
since and, and, um, you know, when, when we didn't have kids, then we were going to almost,
we were going to all of these events together.
Yeah.
I mean, over, I've been to probably about 20 life hacking events.
Personally.
And Justin's been to like a few more.
Yeah.
Um, so that, that was, that was great.
It's been a great opportunity to travel all around.
Do you have any tips for people bringing their wives or girlfriends on trips to life hacking events?
For the ha so tips, tips, let me clarify tips for the hacker and tips for the girlfriend.
I love that.
I feel like people do it very differently, right?
Like depending on personalities, I've seen it done a lot of way by hackers and their partners.
Um, some, I know that Justin, when he goes to a life hacking event, he takes it very seriously
and wants to really respect the program and the company, you know, everyone flying him out and stuff.
So he will spend 98 and a half percent of every trip we take, like actually hiding the target.
Some hackers do not do that.
So if you're not a hacker who like cares to do that, I know I'll do that.
I'm not going to do that.
So if you're not a hacker who like cares to do that, I know a lot of people will like take the plane ticket and hack beforehand,
hopefully be respectful to the programs and stuff, but hack beforehand and then during the event, just kind of enjoy, you know, the cool city or whatever they're flying you out to.
That's totally different, right?
Like if they were taking time off to like be with their partner and travel together, you can do whatever you want.
I was like a couple have fun, chill, do whatever.
We don't do it that way.
Right.
That's correct.
John would be very serious about his hacking.
So I, for the reason, I think, I think it's a lot of people who are going to do that.
But for, I guess, for any partners who are the plus ones on the sidelines for the things, I had to do a lot of work to like not demand his time during those times and like not try to drain or pull or like complain him away from the things that he's doing.
But they are very important and I want to be respectful of his hobby and also his job and his focus, you know, like it takes a lot.
It takes a lot to hack these targets.
That's kind of the point.
So for me, it was a lot of like, okay, if I'm going, I am there to be supportive.
I am not there to take his time.
I'm hopefully there to maybe make some things more efficient for him, help make some more money for both of us.
I love that for us.
And like, let him let him kind of be.
I love that.
Vegas is so long.
I've like brought friends or family and like just, you know, forgot about Justin and done whatever I wanted.
I've done a lot of planning.
Like today we're going to take a bus tour and the next day we're going to rent a car and like drive here and go kayaking and like do all this stuff that Justin has not gotten to do on his vacation.
Yeah, I've never I've been to Vegas five or six times at this point and I've never been to the Grand Canyon.
It's like the easiest thing to get to.
Like every single time we go, I am just lasered in on work and then by the time I'm done, like after Vegas, you're just toasted.
You know, you just want to go home.
Especially Vegas.
Yeah.
But it's Mariah's seen the Grand Canyon like three times and I've never been.
It's beautiful.
It's great.
Yeah.
I still haven't run a donkey down into it.
I've never been into it, which I feel like has got to be the best way to see it.
But maybe sometime.
Did you ever do a helicopter over it?
No, I'm not bougie like that.
Justin is a very bougie.
So sometimes it's nice to not.
I'm not very bougie.
I forgot the audience.
We're talking to guys troll me all the time.
All the hackers are like, Justin spent some money man.
Yeah.
Compared to you guys.
He just has more like he would take a helicopter ride and I would take a donkey, you know, like this is the level.
But he would not take a private jet over the Grand Canyon.
So he's not like bougie bougie.
Thank you.
Or he wastes $10,000 in gambling.
He would not do that.
Yeah.
Actually.
So thanks.
Yeah, you're welcome.
So.
Okay.
So going back, you're saying there's a little bit of a mindset shift for you.
So much of a mindset.
And I know some couples aren't like that, right?
Some couples don't aren't there to spend as much time as possible with their partner.
I totally get that too.
But that's not what I do want in general.
Yeah.
And I think you had a good tip and I think we've had a fun time with it too.
When you're able to bring a friend with you.
Yeah.
That's fun.
A lot of the weekends though, I'll like, maybe I'll try to plan something that I know Justin might want to do.
And like maybe some hackers can join along.
We do a lot of little stuff.
We'll go to like a museum is such a bad example, but we have done that before.
I know Justin doesn't like museums so much.
I don't love museums.
That's totally okay.
Yeah.
Well, but like an event that we can like maybe tag a couple hackers onto that he and his buddies can come to too and like have a fun time for like an evening.
We usually have at least an evening to do something together.
And in general, I just kind of like try to get in my mindset.
Sometimes I'll have like work I need to do on my computer.
Sometimes I'll have just, you know, chill and enjoy the hotel view and like a little food and stuff.
And like a little food with the hackers and like see some old buddies now.
And, but yeah, sometimes I'll do stuff for myself.
And I think that's a really personal decision.
You know, if you, it depends on how much work you want to do for yourself, how much planning you want to do for yourself.
If you can choose to have a fun time traveling by yourself in a really cool city that you're not paying for, like that's obviously going to be the best.
But if it's not worth the effort, then don't go or chill or do whatever you want.
How has that been for you?
What, like, like, do you think you?
Vancouver was one that you were incredibly busy for.
I remember this is like years ago now.
You were like so busy and so unavailable, which was disappointing and early.
So I still wasn't as good as like letting you be.
But Vancouver was so awesome.
Like, so beautiful.
Like you can't, you can go and have a fun time alone in Vancouver.
You know, some of the places just haven't really been worth it to me to like, go through the effort of having a good time by myself.
Right.
But I really do feel like that's personal.
And I think I generally have, if I pick at least one or two things I want to see and either invite you to them and see if you can do them with me or say like, I am going to have a fun time and I am going to see the one or two things I really wanted to see even if he's not free to do them with me.
That's been, that's been best for me.
Just like do one or two good things, make yourself some good memories you can take home and like make it with your time for going.
Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense.
Yeah. I think, I think it could definitely be a very intense time.
And I think hacker one has evolved a little bit now to have that extra day on the end normally after the hacking is done because I think in the beginning they were kind of playing with a little bit and they would try to do like community before the event.
But the thing is the people that are really competitive are, or really taking it seriously are still thinking about hacking that whole time.
Yeah.
So it's much nicer to have it on the back end of that.
Now everything's out of my brain.
Everything's done.
You can't even, everything's a dupe now anyway.
Yeah.
Everything's a dupe now anyway.
That's too real.
Um, you know, or the submissions are closed, right?
Yeah.
And, um, and then you can go and have a relaxing day together.
Yeah, exactly.
That's great.
And like they often will do something so fun.
Like we've like boated down the Thames, you know, like, and we've got to see like an NBA game, you know, just like random stuff that is like scheduled and there's a bus and like you go and the hackers go, you know?
So like we've gotten to do a bunch, they'll get me tickets too, which is great.
I've like grown into that, right?
The more I like showed up, the more we've like grown into it.
Cause you know, I was, I didn't even ask the first time and I wasn't sure if I'd get through the door.
Now I get through the door, but they boot me out for show and tells.
So I don't have many recent show and tells cause they're all like, you know what?
NDA.
Hearing about bugs live on a series or something.
I can go sell that information to nation state or something.
I don't know.
You know, it makes sense.
It's just not as fun, you know?
Yeah.
But it makes sense.
I think they should just have some NDAs there and then you can just sign it and stay.
Yeah.
I mean, but if you're going to sell and sell information for millions of dollars, an NDA is not going to stop you from selling information for millions of dollars.
Well then it doesn't, it doesn't, you know, do anything anyway.
It doesn't do anything.
It's a lawyer thing for sure.
It's limited liability.
I get it.
Yeah.
You don't need randos watching.
It just, it's just more fun to watch.
It makes sense.
Um, what it had, like, what was your favorite activity that you've done at a live hacking
event?
Um, either as a part of like hacker one sponsored stuff or.
I think voting the Thames was the best.
I mean, like you can't be voting the Thames.
Yeah.
That was really good.
That was the first time I've been to London.
And like, probably not something I would have sprung for if I, if we had been on a trip ourselves,
you know, I'd be like, oh, renting a boat.
It's probably not even that expensive.
Is it pronounced Thames?
Is it Thames?
I have no idea what it is.
Yeah.
Um, that nice big river in London.
Big old river.
By the clock.
That was, that was.
And that big old other building.
That was really, that was really fun time.
I agree.
I think boating excursions.
So nice.
Really nice.
Uh, integrity also did one of those for, uh, an event.
Yeah.
I think it was Portugal and, uh, that one was a little bit choppier, but it was still amazing.
So I think, um, I have really been grateful to be included on like events like that.
With hacker one specifically, um, to not be program or like platform agnostic.
Yeah.
They have been very kind to me as a way to incentivize Justin to continue to do a good job, which has been very effective for them.
So I think it's a good investment on their part.
Yeah.
I'm sure there's like a hundred great things we've done.
I'm not thinking of all of them right now, but some of the favorite things that I've done is like, we went to Spain for a big life hacking event.
Yeah.
And I had my family and a really good friend, um, Kodai there with us.
And I had like this massive itinerary that I made for us.
And like, we were just like doing stuff and seeing stuff for days and days.
We walked like,
Barcelona was beautiful too.
Barcelona was so beautiful and never been.
And we walked like 20,000 steps a day and saw like a billion things.
And then from Barcelona, we took a big trip that I planned around Europe to like Andorra, France, um, Monaco.
Yeah.
We like swung around the coast and like did all the things that I wanted to do because I planned it.
And we just also do cool things.
Carcassonne France was really pretty.
So just like, you know, that's how we've done it, especially on the bigger trips, like international trips as we've like pivoted it to, you can change your flight out to whenever you want.
It doesn't have to be the day they stop paying for your hotel.
Right.
I don't know if that's common knowledge, but you can ask them to fly you out five weeks later if you want to spend some extra time in Japan or whatever.
Like, I think there's like a limit.
Maybe not five weeks.
And that might be like two weeks or something, but you know, talk to the community.
That's plenty of time for our vacation.
Yeah.
They can make it happen.
So we've like pivoted and had a lot of fun with that.
Um, yeah, you know, just work with your partner, figure out what they want to do, figure out what you want to do.
And if it doesn't sound fun to be alone for an entire weekend, then, um, maybe don't do it if that's the partner you have.
Okay.
So switching, switching, uh, speed a little bit here away from the live hacking events.
Um, one of the things I've talked to the audience on critical thinking about a lot is how, um, you had, were really pivotal in the,
uh, decision to go full-time bug bounty.
Yeah.
Um, and then me maintaining my mental health, uh, dirt, you know, while doing full-time bug bounty for so long, specifically in the arena of like not putting my self-worth in my performance as a hacker.
Um, so can you talk a little bit about that decision to go full-time bug bounty and, you know, what our thought process was like, and then also not finding your self-worth in, in your, uh, you know, performance as a hacker.
Yeah.
Well, I think that he could have started full-time bug bounty, like a lot before he did.
Like he chose to get a full-time job out of college and do bug bounty.
Cause remember we were still in college when he went to his first live hacking event, even.
And then after that was pretty often, you know, every few months and being invited to more events and stuff.
So he seemed like he was doing well, but he still looks like accepted a full-time job out of college and did that for a year or two for a while.
Um, also Justin, you know, most people don't have this problem.
Justin has never failed to get a job.
He's applied for, right?
Justin has gotten jobs.
He hasn't applied for just people who will be your big Justin.
Please work for us.
No, no, no.
This is real coming from someone who doesn't have the same experience and has like gone months, you know, looking for a job and trying to get something that works for me.
And like, then not liked my jobs, like had a much more difficult and unpleasant, like job in general, had many more job interviews where I didn't get the job.
It's totally different.
Right.
And your skill sets in demand and your personality is in demand.
You're just very lovable and likable and great, a great asset on a team.
So coming from specifically where he was, he did not need a job out of college.
He did not need it to ensure that he would get a job later in life.
Like he, we, he will always be employable.
So if he stays how he is, even if he doesn't improve for the rest of his life, right?
If he stays how he is, he is incredibly employable.
So that would be, I think maybe the biggest concern for people.
If you know, you were transitioning out of college is like, what do I feel like this?
Like, what if I, you know, then have like a two year resume gap or whatever, whatever.
One, he was already being very successful.
Like he was already finding bugs in his very, very limited time.
I made sure it was very limited because he was working a full time job and we were recently married.
So very limited amount of time to hack.
He was finding stuff.
And I think that Matt, I think that matters, you know, and especially like if you don't know, you want to do it, you want to make sure you're in a position that you can get a job.
Like I think wanting a bailout from bug bounty is totally reasonable.
Yeah, it just wasn't a problem for you.
And we had, we had financial margin.
We had a track record of me doing bug bounty part time and making almost as much or more actually than my full time salary.
Yeah. And you had done that for like a year.
And I had tried to, again, I had like tried to let him hack a little bit, but the full time job plus bug bounty was not for an early marriage.
In my opinion, not, it's not great.
Yeah. It was hard in the beginning for sure.
I mean, you add anything to a full time job in an early marriage, like grad school or any other commitment to your time.
And it's probably, I mean, just be married.
That's my vote.
But, but you know, something you really like, something you're really good at.
It did, but it worked out as a pivot.
It did not work out as a long term bug bounty and full time job.
And that's part of why I really pushed it.
And part of why I still push it.
This guy still is like, what if I got a job or what if I started another company or what if I had 16 more different pivots?
More so the latter.
But yeah.
Both.
But that's true.
I would, I, I definitely considered job offers from Google and from like a government entity.
So I think, I think that, but yeah, lately more so on the entrepreneurial side, like wouldn't it be great if I just like started this other company and you're like, literally don't even think about it.
Yeah. So for us, like he, I think you even paid down our college debt while we were still in college.
And I'm like, in our like one year of college, we went from like, you know, call two people of collegiate debt to like, wait, we just positive.
Yeah.
We're like, we're not negative anymore.
That's crazy.
And that to us was really important.
We didn't want to like hold all of the loans and like hold the weight from other loans.
So we chose to pay all those down.
Um, and so we already saw that like he could make money from it.
And so I more than him was like, okay, so when are you quitting your job?
As soon as he got a job, like this is not this.
And this is like not awesome.
And clearly this one is working better for us.
Do you remember how I responded to that at the time?
Because I feel like we've merged our mentality so much.
No, no.
Well, unstable income.
Well, healthcare.
What?
Oh, that's sorry.
That's how I remember it.
Oh my gosh, Mariah.
I just never know if I'm going to get paid though.
Like what if they just stop paying me money for the bugs that I find?
So that's how I remember it.
Wow.
Okay.
That should be an, man, I can hear my, um, my mentees right now just laughing their heads off because now I have so much, you know, merged this mentality with Mariah.
Um, and by merge, I mean, taken her mentality, uh, about it that I'm like constantly yelling at my friends that are doing well in book bounty.
Like, Hey dude, if you don't want to be at this job that you hate, just do well in book bounty.
Yeah.
Like you can take the risk.
Now is the time to take it.
You're young.
You don't have any, you know, additional things you need to pay or responsibilities or anything.
Spouses or illegitimate children.
Yeah, some of them are single.
Some of them are, yeah, exactly.
And, and so like, I think that there's a lot of, yeah, flexibility that I see now that I didn't see at the time.
And I was glad you really, I was really glad you had the foresight to see that.
You also, I mean, I wasn't really pushing for it.
It was, you're often a pretty big risk averse guy, right?
And so by the time we made the decision, we, it wasn't a risk.
It truly was, there was no risk in it.
You had months of success, months of at least being able to pay our bills.
We didn't even pay our bills on such a small amount of time invested.
And yeah, I think, I think when you chose to do it, you chose to do it zero risk, really.
And like I said, you're very, you personally are very employable.
So worst case scenario, you get a job again, which puts you exactly back where you were.
Right.
But you also liked your job and you liked your coworkers.
And so I get that.
I mean, there's a lot that needs to go into decision to being full-time bug bounty.
Like if you don't want to be home alone or at a cafe alone every single day of your life, like that's a super reasonable decision.
Justin loves to wall himself off and like focus on his work for an entire day for an entire week.
You know, like that vibes with you.
Like, that's great.
I could not do it.
Would not do it.
You're doing, you do great.
I wish for you.
But yeah, I think by the time we decided to do it, it was like really no risk.
Like you had enough of a track record.
You were employable again.
And we were doing great.
Felt like such a risk to me, man.
It felt like such a risk.
But, but you know, you're right.
I mean, we had a track record.
We had financial margin.
That savings.
When you, when you, when you think about, I just hear these stories of people being like,
all right, well, I'm going to like put my rent on a credit card to like do this thing that I really want to do.
And I'm like, that is, that is, that is dicey, you know?
And, and so there are definitely people out there that take a lot more risk than we did in that situation.
Okay.
So, you know, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, that answered the question about like going full-time bug bounty, you know, that was our thought process of like,
we earned enough, you know, we had minimized the risk.
We were going to move to Japan, right?
That was that same time.
I really do feel like it's such a personal decision.
And I think it's a personal decision to start and a personal decision to continue.
Right.
And so we've made both used to chose to start and many people will try full-time bug bounty and get hit some of the cons and say,
this isn't for me.
And that's totally fine.
Like a lot of people have done it for years and then been like, hey, I don't like hustling this much.
Like, I don't like earning every penny I make like correlatively.
Yeah.
Right.
Like I want to be able to show up and do a good job at my job and get paid whether or not,
which is fair.
Yeah.
I think that's totally fair.
And it's like, and you can clock out at the end of the day.
You know, some people have a hard time quitting work when they are doing full-time bug bounty.
Yeah.
You know, it's, it's all personal decisions and that's totally fine.
Um, for us though, the continued decision is based on all the pros.
Right.
So like the cons are still there.
What, what cons have I experienced in full-time bug bounty?
Definitely.
I mean, which ones have you talked me out of slash, uh, supported me through?
The ones I've seen for you are not the ones that I see for the most commonly, honestly, like the isolation is not a problem for you.
Um, and I manage his social calendar a little bit so that he doesn't have, he doesn't become like a,
I don't lose the friends that I already have.
Yeah.
Um, but like the work isolation is not a problem for you.
And the making enough money is not a problem for you.
Right.
I know some hackers, especially when they're just starting, like it's hard to like actually be making enough money to pay your bills, which I think is fair.
Um, those are like maybe the two most serious problems that can happen.
Justin doesn't have those.
So I'd say your next problems you have are like, it's like, I am garbage.
If I'm not making enough money for my family and enough money is like subjective.
He's always making enough money for us to like live and be well.
But I'll set aggressive goals for it.
Yeah.
Which is great.
I think aggressive goals are also awesome.
They were great for you.
Um, until they don't.
Right.
And then also like the, it's not working spiral of like this.
I love how she's got a name for this, but it's not working spiral.
Yeah.
Like I need to put that on a t-shirt.
This one was a dupe.
I found an almost bug.
It ended up not being a bug.
You know, like you hit a couple different flavored lumps, you know?
Yeah.
Like you hit a couple different problems.
Flavored lumps.
And then, and then it gets into the, I'm not working, it's not working spiral.
Right.
And then, especially this is the first like year or two, right?
We're like more than that into it, but the first year or two, especially like you hit like
two dupes in a month and you're like, this was supposed to pay my bills or you.
And like this one triage is like mean or wrong.
And you have to tell them something seven times, you know, like this is a bug.
I need it to be a bug.
And it's a bug.
Like, you know, like you had a couple different things and.
And then you start rethink, you start wasting your time rethinking your life decisions.
And you know, it makes sense like lose motivation and like lose energy temporarily when you're
disappointed, right?
That's just what disappointment in life does sometimes.
But like, but then to start wasting your time rethinking all of your decisions and being
like maybe I'm not cut out for this.
Like it is truly a waste of time to reevaluate.
That's maybe another good takeaway.
If you're going to do full time bug bounty or you're going to try it, right?
You're in transition.
Don't waste your time reevaluating.
Just commit to it hard.
Give yourself.
Yeah.
Whatever savings you have, whatever time you have, three months.
And also don't miss metric, right?
Like sometimes this happens to you too.
Sometimes Justin will be like, I didn't find.
Oh shit, this is like therapy.
Okay.
All right.
Tell me.
I didn't find enough bugs this month, right?
Whatever that is.
I didn't, I wasn't as successful this month as I wanted.
You know, now I'm rethinking decisions.
Okay.
We're going to pause it.
We're going to actually look at what you've done.
Because usually when that happens for Justin, it's like, yeah, well, we went on a vacation
for like nine days.
We had like this thing implode in our social life.
We had like this family member that needed something.
We had three hour work days for two weeks straight and the vacation for the rest of the
month, like, oh no, you didn't find a full time, like 40 hour work weeks worth of bugs every
single week for four weeks when not a single week was a real work week.
Like, don't get caught up on that.
If you're going to throw a pity party, like you need to have actually worked 40 hours a
week to then be like, wait, maybe this isn't working.
So you guys see, this is what I get.
Like, just to be clear, like, like, you know, I think I show up to these podcasts, like, you
know, pretty amped for bug bounty and like, and like, pretty in favor of it.
But there are some times when I'm really down about it.
And then she gives me one of these, like, yeah, what the heck are you doing?
Pep talks where we talk through all of the benefits of the lifestyle that we have with
full time bug bounty.
And it makes me realize that, oh, my, my dupe streak or like, you know, me having to
respond to this report, you know, five times before the triage triages it is not actually
that bad.
And this is a really awesome setup.
Or sometimes I think unfairly programs have like underrated bugs, you know, programs make
a mistake.
There are a lot of problems you'll run into.
But if you're truly reconsidering doing full time bug bounty, you need to make sure all
your information's right.
Like you may not reevaluate if you haven't gotten your results that you want.
Do you hear this?
If you also haven't done the work that you needed to do, right?
Yeah.
Like, and it's easy for a week to see the way.
You may not reevaluate, she says.
You need to decide beforehand.
Like you just, I just see so many hackers, some of your mentees that I won't call out
by name.
Yeah.
And like just hackers in general, wasting so much time and energy reevaluating based on
garbage facts, right?
Like you got to get your facts right.
You got to know how much you're putting into it before you evaluating how well you're doing
or what you're getting out of it.
Like you have to make sure your output is, is matching.
You know, it's just not worth it.
You cannot waste that much time reevaluating that I've seen some people waste.
Yeah, I feel that.
So, you know, you just gave an excellent pep talk to me in this situation and all the hackers
listening.
So hopefully people will take that.
Could you, could you take a moment to brag on yourself a little bit?
And if you don't, then I will, on like how having a, a stable, supportive relationship
is, is important for full-time bug bounty.
And like, you want me to tell them how important that I am to your success.
Exactly.
That is what I want.
Or would you like me to do it?
I can do it too.
I feel like people are so different, you know, like I know our relationship is not going
to be everyone's relationship.
I also, I think I saw on your doc, some of the things like how to be a better, like hacker
spouse, like as the hacker part two, I'd love to go into that.
So, um, yeah, well, you know, and for us, it's okay.
I'm not going to try to give super broadly applicable advice because it's too broad.
So all I can say what I do to support you.
Yeah.
And so one of the biggest things we did was we were both working full-time jobs and doing
hacking on the side, right?
So full-time, full-time above full-time, right?
That was not it for us.
That did not work.
We were like stressed.
I would get home from work.
He would stay home working for both of his jobs.
We would have like no food, no one to cook.
If we cooked, neither of us wanted to clean up.
It was like very bad vibes.
Like, and understandably, because we're both exhausted.
It's like 630.
We'll have maybe, maybe as late as seven when we finish like making, eating dinner.
We like ate out a lot, which we don't like to do all the time.
And then we just be exhausted.
We just go to bed and start the next day.
And I don't like that life cycle, right?
Like I know that's a really, probably the most, at least in America, the most common life cycle is like you spend your entire day working.
You spend your entire evening.
Staying alive.
Barely living.
Getting behind on your, your crap that you will need to do.
Pushing that till Saturday.
Like, oh, I need to clean the house.
I need to like go grocery shopping and like meal prep or whatever.
And then you start your next week already.
And that for us was like, this is such a bad lifestyle.
What, what can we do at this point to change that?
So I quit my job, which was great.
You know, like it, I'm very pro like domestic tasks are not for the females alone.
You know, like labor should be split equally.
But then we just reduced the labor dramatically by me quitting a job.
Right.
And so now I can take domestic tasks and, and more.
And our real estate portfolio and that sort of thing.
Yeah. Like property management, like meal prep, meal planning, grocery shopping, all the laundry.
I will often personally like make and deliver food to Justin's desk and then like clean up his desk and garbage afterwards.
And like that to me is, is actually totally fine.
And sometimes it's not.
And sometimes I'm like, Justin, I feel like you're treating me like a maid.
And then we have that conversation and then we fix it.
You know, I'll try to be, I'll try to be, I mean, it ebbs and flows with my level of engagement on that front.
Because sometimes I'll just be so in the zone and then I'll look down and there's food and then I'll, you know, eat it.
And then I'll, I'll get back in the zone.
I looked down and the plate's gone.
And I'm like, but it, uh, okay.
This is real for him too.
Like his focus is crazy.
He, he is, if anything, too focused, which I know is not a problem.
Most people have.
Um, yeah.
So for me, I, you know, I've just taken on a lot of the stuff.
I've taken on our whole social calendar.
Like I said, I actively plan him like play dates with his friends and like,
Play dates.
You don't have to act like I'm a kid.
Geez.
You can play with your friends.
By the way, when's the next play date?
Yeah, I know.
Um, so I think that, I think that's a big piece.
And I put a lot of like planning and work into our like vacations, like our family vacation stuff.
I got tons of research and planning and stuff.
And I just take on what I feel like I can take on.
For us, that's how we've distributed labor.
And for us that works as like a hacker couple.
And it's a really good way to support him.
So it takes a lot of the mental load off of him intentionally, right?
Like he doesn't have to think about what we're eating.
He doesn't have to think about his macros, right?
There's going to be like protein for dinner, you know, like, or worry about it.
And like, I also do a lot of driving for our kid and stuff too.
So I also wanted to, so on the kid note, you know, we recently, we recently have a kid in
our home and, um, there's, there's definitely some changes that come along with that.
Uh, and I think one of the great things about being full-time book bounty was when, uh, the
kid is away at school, um, we also can have time together, right?
Cause you're, I'm self-employed and you are also self-employed, right?
So we can adjust our schedules.
And even if that means I need to work a little bit later or something like that, we can still
go on a date or like hang out or whatever.
Um, and, and, and talk, you know, cause by the time you get your, your kid to bed, sometimes
it's like, Oh, I'm just going to fall asleep.
Um, so I think that's been really positive for us as well.
Um, for me too, I mean, especially since we're both at home, right?
So if both people are at home, Justin has said that like, if he's hacking and I come
in and ask him like a random question, right?
Like what about tomorrow?
What about this plan?
Whatever.
And then he has to go back to hacking.
It wastes like 10 to 15 minutes of cognitive time for him.
And that like correlated to like our dollars per hour wage is important, right?
Like I don't want to waste 15 minutes of your time unnecessarily.
Right.
You're very cognizant of that now.
And I think that's been an evolution.
Huge change.
But yeah, I think when she'll group things too, so she'll come in, you know, she'll still
come in and interrupt me from time to time, but it's like, she's got three disjointed questions,
you know, that she clearly has been stacking up.
Um, and then we'll get those done and then knock it out and we'll, we'll go along.
If it like, I appreciate that a lot.
Cause you know, I respect my own time as well.
So if it, if the things are too much in the way of me getting what I need done done, you
know, like this is a house decision we need to make, this is a school thing.
And this is a social thing.
I got three and a half people waiting for me.
And now I can't really like do the rest of my stuff before I get back to these people on these things.
Yeah.
I'll, I'll for sure interrupt him.
But like, for me, it was definitely a big change from being like, you know, I very much value.
Like people respecting my time.
And like, if I need something like responding to that.
Right.
But in within like the bounds of it's just boundaries.
For working at home.
Right.
Like within the boundaries of working at home and like, for sure.
Clear expectations.
You know, you want to respect each other's time.
So.
Yeah.
Could you, could you talk a little bit about the goal system that you set up to motivate
me and how that's worked in our bug bounty career?
Yeah.
I think part of it.
So if you're doing bug bounty, you're assuming a lot of work.
Right.
You have a lot of work.
You got a lot of emotional ups and downs.
Like life hacking events are one thing.
Just month to month, day to day, people not paying you what you hope to be paid.
This, you know, even just hitting one dupe, you know, that's always a huge bummer.
Like you have expected something and it didn't come through.
So one thing, because it's a bounty system and the more work, the more you can focus,
the more you can have fun, the more you can make your life pleasant instead of miserable.
Right.
Really?
The more money you make in bug bounty.
Like if you're just sitting there miserable, you're probably not.
It's a very applicable thing.
Yeah.
You're probably not focusing well.
You're probably not excited to try something new.
You're probably not in it.
And if you're not in it, you're not going to be making money.
It's such a weird system like that.
Let me, I'm going to just pause you for just a second, because there's an article by Sam
Curry on why it's entitled, I think why you shouldn't become a bug bounty hunter or something
like that.
Um, and I'm not sure I agree with all of the takes in there.
I think we've mentioned it on the podcast once or twice, but, um, I think it's
a good thing.
I think it's a good thing.
You just got to keep things prioritized.
Yeah.
So the goals the goal system that we set up, I guess, was
specifically surrounding the live hacking events.
This is speaking to motivation.
That's why I was talking about that.
Yeah.
So you you want to keep yourself positively motivated for how much work you're getting.
You're doing it.
So this was a system.
I think I just came up with it.
Yeah, you came up with it.
Because we generally are pretty frugal.
And we were right at first we were like paying off all our college debts and then we were like saving money so that we weren't like, like,
we could have some flexibility.
Go full time money.
Exactly.
Like, keep some savings in the bank.
And then we were like choosing to go to these live hacking events and like not really do anything, like not celebrate them, not have a lot of fun because we were just in the like pay off the debt mindset.
And I was like, this isn't this isn't fun.
And if it's not fun, it's not going to keep going well.
So we pretty early on, we did like a goal system, right?
So he would come up with goals for himself and tier them.
Like if I make like 10 monies, I'll get.
10 monies.
I love you so much.
This is like a one to 10 scale, right?
Yeah.
If I make 10 monies, this is like the grand prize.
If I make like seven monies, this is the next prize.
And if I make like four monies, this is my like low ball prize.
So like if he makes and then if he doesn't reach even his lowest goal, which is aggressive for Justin generally, then he doesn't.
We just don't.
We don't get a price.
He pretty much always gets at least his lowest goal.
I don't know that you've ever not gotten the lowest goal.
I don't think so.
Maybe once, maybe.
But the lowest one is usually like a one to $200 prize or one to $500 prize, like a new coffee maker, you know, like an appliance is already a couple hundred dollars.
You know, so we'll do something that like.
My next coffee maker will be more than a couple hundred dollars, but we'll get to that later.
Or like this one, like a pull up bar for the garage, you know, installed or something like that.
Like, you know, it'll be like something little, but something and even something maybe we would have wanted to do anyway, but we'll try to like prolong it a little bit to like be a reward instead of just be something that we sink money into.
And then like the biggest you got a car out of one of them.
Yeah.
And a hot tub, right?
And a hot tub.
And I think that's the one that had the most value.
And I think it's interesting because obviously, you know, we're making enough money where we could just go buy any of these things.
But I think gamifying it as well really appeals to me.
Oh, you didn't get the hot tub this time.
Guess we'll have to wait till next time.
Yeah.
And I think I think also Mariah very emphatically insisting that I follow through with the purchase after the event.
It was was really big because, you know, I'd be like, oh, well, you know, it's like seven thousand dollars for this hot tub or whatever.
Plus the electrical. It was like, yeah, no, it was a lot for the electrical work out of the hot tub.
And we had to get a patio under the hot tub to like have a flat surface.
Yeah. So it was a lot. But you were insistent that I followed through with that because that's you have to keep those promises to yourself.
And and and it I think that was that was great.
That was kind of what we needed there.
And it's always a percentage, right? Like if he makes, you know, twenty thousand dollars an event, he's never going to spend twenty thousand dollars from that event.
Oh, no. Yeah. On like a small toys, right on stuff we don't need.
I mean, we might we'll spend it on like rent and investments and stuff, but we're not going to spend it for fun.
It's always like a scaling percentage of.
So if he makes a little money, he gets a little thing.
And if he makes a lot of money, he gets a bigger thing. But it's still like not, you know, we're not going to spend all of the money at once.
And that's a personal finance decision for us, too, is we don't want like lifestyle creep to control our entire lives.
And we really don't want to trap ourselves into having to make as much money as we're making now either.
Right. Like we want to live below our means so that if we do ever want to pivot for any reason.
And honestly, like we've had this kid a kid since May.
So sometime some some some undisclosed time.
Yeah, I don't know what month it is, honestly, anyway, but a few months and like are he has worked so much less. Right.
Like we've been we spending a lot of time strategizing like, oh, what do we do?
Like this is a new thing we've never done before.
You know, this is a half grown child like she's already come with a lot of pre-programming and like we're, you know, we're every week, not every day, every week.
There's something like, you know, we've never seen this before in our life.
And now parenting is interesting.
So we've chosen to spend a ton of time on it.
Like and he has not for months and months not worked probably one full work week, maybe a full week around a life hacking event.
Yeah, except for the live hacking events.
Vegas was a lot.
You know, there's been a lot of fragmentation, but I think I think we're working back towards that that direction of getting full time, you know, getting dedicated hacking time in place.
But it it's definitely an adjustment and the having the flexibility to prioritize things like, hey, let's strategize.
Hey, let's let's talk about stuff.
Hey, let's spend some me and you time because, you know, the rest of our life is being, you know, dominated by this new parental responsibility.
Exactly. So to bring that around, we don't we personally don't want to trap ourselves into having to make as much money as we're making.
Hmm. So we always are under spending for stuff because we want to be able to take months and months off to like slowly transition into different things.
And trying to convert those large spikes of income that come in with bug bounty into longer term passive income, which is an area that Mariah really excels in because she can take that.
She has experience with real estate investing and, you know, getting that into various, you know, passive cash flowing streams.
We make a really good team, too, because I think I do have a lot of vision and ideas and desires.
And Justin is has a lot of I like making that happen, like super skillful.
He loves to love me.
And so I'll get a desire or an idea and it'll be like three fourths of the way baked.
And I'm like, hey, Justin, this is like a lot of hard stuff.
Can you like can we do this?
And then he says, yes.
And then we get every, you know, we do what we want.
And it's it's a really good look like moving to Japan.
You know, I had all the like the groundwork and the vision and some of the logistics.
But like I if I had had to move to Japan to myself, I would have had to like be an English teacher and like live on nothing and like all of these things.
And with Justin, the whole idea was like the whole vision was able to change and we could make something way better than my idea together.
Yeah, I think I think we have a lot of you have a lot of great vision for our family unit.
And then I have a lot of follow through and making it happen and long term follow through.
Long term follow through.
And I think we also have various skills where they they overlap in a really or don't overlap in a really positive way.
Like a lot of the supportive stuff that you that you do.
I suck at cooking.
She she's an amazing cook and is very cognizant of like, oh, it's time to eat.
Justin is probably even though he doesn't know it, he's low on energy, you know, and and then, you know, me handling the paperwork side of the real estate stuff.
You handling the like hands, you know, boots on the ground to do the paperwork stuff most of the time.
Yeah, it works out really well.
I want to circle back around again.
I know we got to do right to prizes and rewards for your work.
Yeah, like even if you're not doing a live hacking event, you could do this with your like monthly incomes a little hard with bug bounding because it really changes.
But maybe like three month club income or something like that would be a better way to do it if you're not at the point where you're going to live hacking events.
Yeah, like definitely set yourself goals and reward yourself.
You know, and I kind of and it was the way I was raised to I kind of thought that like buying yourself stuff ever was like indulgent.
Like we always waited till Christmas to get something that we wanted.
Like we never bought stuff we wanted like ever.
We just didn't do it.
And my parents didn't and we didn't and it didn't happen.
So I thought it was like overindulgent to just buy something that you wanted for like 50 bucks, 100 bucks.
I was like, no, we're not.
We're not going to do that.
But like I really do feel like for bug bounty specifically, it's an investment in yourself and your like motivation because motivation is the only thing that's going to make you money in bug bounty or like grind.
You can grind through it.
You don't need motivation if you're grinding.
But like, you know, you want to keep yourself in a positive cycle.
It's not a salary.
It's not sustainable if you're just grinding the whole time.
Yeah, it's not a salary job.
So you shouldn't treat your income like you have a salaried income and be like, oh, 50% goes to this bucket.
20% goes to this bucket at all times because it's inherently has to be flexible.
But we have different categories.
This is what I've been trying to get back to.
We have different categories of prizes and I have it written down somewhere formally if we ever need to like release the formal list.
But there's like just to help you think of things that you can spend your money on if, you know, unless you're someone like Noggle who has plenty of things to spend money on.
Pretty called Noggle out on like that.
I like that.
Or Sam Gurry or, you know, there are lots of people who spend a lot of money on a lot of things.
But if you're not, if that doesn't come naturally to you, like it didn't come naturally to me, we formalized buckets of fun spending money because not everything is a toy for yourself.
So, right.
There are like fun stuff that you want for yourself that you don't need.
Right.
And I think even within that, there's categories.
Like a new video game system and video games is like one thing.
But like maybe a hot tub and a patio is like also a social investment and also personal health investment.
Home improvement.
Yeah.
Buy yourself a physical trainer.
Sorry, don't buy them.
Buy their services.
Right.
Subscribe to a physical trainer.
Experiences is another one.
Experience is a huge one.
Vacations or classes like take a class on something that you're interested in a dance class, whatever gifts for other people like that, you know, like pro social gifts is a whole bucket of like people don't usually buy their friend a car.
But if you get to the financial point where you can buy someone who needs a car a car, do that.
Yeah.
Like do that as a pleasure spending for yourself.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Like gift yourself the gift of giving someone else a car like that is an awesome bucket.
Right.
And that can be a goal for your thing.
So it doesn't have to be you don't have to buy yourself a hot tub.
You can buy your dad a car, you know, like.
Yeah.
And I think a lot of hackers do spread that that money around, which is which is cool.
All right.
Wait.
Well, okay.
Wrap it up because we got to get to this list.
Okay.
I also want to say another like another category of like prize self prize, but in a different like idea is is like one is investment.
Like getting yourself an investment you're excited about.
It can also be a gift for yourself.
Like you can have a if I make this much money, I get to even like buy a single stock or something, right?
Like something that maybe you wouldn't have invested in any way.
Like, but you're excited to try something spend, you know, 30% of your thing on that.
And then the last one is like just charitable is 30% an option.
I didn't know if we were doing 30%
We'll talk about it for the next event.
Who knows?
Maybe I'll do that.
Charitable gifts in general.
So instead of like a pro social gift, like a gift to someone, you know, and you can immediately receive like gratification back from you can also like donate to a charity.
Like I know maybe that sounds a little silly to say, but I feel like some people who should really consider this just don't consider it like helps with the tax burden too because bug money is very tax painful.
I would say we give away at least 10 to 15% of our gross income, not even like our post profit.
Like we give away a ton of money.
And that is awesome.
Like, I love that for us.
I love that for charities and individuals that we like help out in life.
Like pick a charity you like, pick a cause you like, pick there are like places you can donate that spread out, you know, your gift to like, you know, a percent goes here, a percent goes here.
You can pick a bulk charity, whatever you want to do.
Like you can put good things in the world with your money and it doesn't all have to be for yourself either.
So just throwing that out there.
That's just my pitch.
Yeah, that was like the last bucket I can think of right now.
So we have another round of applause here.
Very good.
One of the things that I want to highlight here is that clearly she's very passionate about all of this, right, which I think is really keeps energy up for us.
And I think is is just an amazing blessing to me to see to have her energized about optimizing, you know, my career path and my motivation and the utilization of the upsides of the path that we've chosen.
So I'm really grateful for that.
I think in general, being proud of yourself is better for you than having an extra 10K laying around. Right?
Yeah.
The lifestyle you're living of.
The lifestyle you're living, the choices you're making, like be a generous person.
Make sure you're someone you like, even though you're like putting all this effort in, you're putting all this work in, like you're doing all this learning.
Like, I know that it's a grind to do bug bounty, but like, make sure at the end of the day, you are someone that you like.
And if you're not make better decisions, you know, I think that's very doable.
Yeah, you guys can see why I am on the path that I am on.
It's because of excellent wisdom from Raya like this.
We do have to wrap it.
This one's getting a little long, but I want to talk about one last or I think that's a great idea.
One last or I guess two last sections of how to care for your hacker specifically and how to care for your hacker wife.
So what you know, the majority of our audience here is, you know, are the technical are the are the bug bounty people. Right.
And how can.
Yeah, let's actually just jump to that second one.
How can we.
Let me summarize the first one real quick.
I think you talked about a lot of stuff.
Yeah, we did.
I spent a lot of time trying to assist him because financially and personally, it makes a lot of sense for me to assist.
His work, it's money efficient for me to not work and help him work better.
So like foods and stuff is what I do for him.
Definitely protect their space and time and like brain power.
It's hacking is really hard.
It's really cognitively hard.
So like make sure you.
You just try to give them space to do their thing and like be there when they need to pout and tell them to suck it up.
About dupes.
And yeah, just encourage them and like, you know, just love them.
Just be nice and kind and patient as much as you can.
So I love it.
I love your voice when you said just love them.
Just love them.
Um, okay.
So how can we as bug bounty hunters and people that are spending.
So I think, you know, most of the bug bounty hunters out there are doing this work after their work hours.
Right.
So it it's it's it can feel like a very work heavy environment.
How can we love our our girlfriends and our spouses, etc.
Um, I feel like there's there would be so many different answers to like if it's a girlfriend, if it's a marriage partner, if it's a someone you have children with.
Right.
Like, right.
I think there are lots of obviously lots of things of balance in life.
Um, my biggest one personally is like, if you say you are or are not going to do something, you must do or not do that thing.
Like if you say, hey, I'm going to be off work by six o'clock.
You be off work by six o'clock or or before six o'clock, have a thorough conversation with your spouse about five, five, five thirty.
If you're like really into something.
And, you know, in general, I try to be supportive, too, because like I like it when we make money, too.
Right. So it's not always like I know you said six o'clock, but it is like, hey, if it's six fifteen and you said you're going to be off at six o'clock, we haven't had a conversation about it.
That is always a bad move.
You cannot do that to your spouse, especially since you are requiring so much flexibility of them in general.
Like we said, like it is OK to like need more time to work sometimes.
But if you expect that without communicating that you're going to take your whole relationship, like that's going to be such a bad, such a bad look.
Yeah. And I think one of the other things that I've recently talked to another hacker about is sort of this concept of building up relational equity before there's about to be a drain.
Yeah. So if I know like, hey, there's about to be a live hacking. Yeah. Like, let's go. Let's go on dates.
Let's, you know, really pour into the relationship and get ourselves in like a, you know, ten out of ten love bar fully full.
Yeah. You know, place before that live hacking events even starts because, you know, during that time period, I am juggling so many things I might make some, you know, mistakes and hurt you.
And, you know, it's better to have that that connection both both from like a you supporting me perspective and for me caring for you during this really intense time.
So I think that's something we've also done pretty well. Yeah. I think just communicating and maybe this is more of a you problem than an everyone problem.
Oh, I think that Justin sometimes doesn't notice what he needs, so he doesn't communicate what he needs. So like it took us two years to just get to the point where we were like, oh, he needs to be interrupted less when he's working like that should not have been like a two year process.
Right. But like recognize your and you're trying to try to recognize yourself what you do need, like what you do need and support.
But if your partner is not on board for you to be working every evening of the week hacking when you're working every day and you have a kid like don't do that.
Yeah. Just don't. Yeah. I mean, there's there's other alternatives to that, too.
I mean, like you sleep later than I do. I wake up earlier. Right. And so if you need to flip that around from evenings to mornings, if it's really important for you to get it done, start a few days.
Start at 4am. Start at 5am.
Or one of the one of the things that I suggest as well is find a job that is project oriented.
So, you know, have conversations with your boss. I'm not ever saying like, you know, do this behind your company's back or whatever.
But, you know, find a job where it's like, hey, you complete this thing by this time.
I don't care how you do it. Right. I don't care what you what else you do with your work time. Right.
And then a lot of jobs are like and then get really good at your job and free up some time and then use that time to do bug bounty.
I think that's a great I think that's a great framework. Like if it's important enough for you to want to override what your partner wants.
Right. Like if it's that important to you, then make your own time for it. Like make the 5am to 9am time before you have to go to work.
Four hours is a ton of time and it's really inconvenient, but it's much better than sucking that time away from your partner in the evening.
If that's become a conflict in your relationship or find some compromise, right?
Find some compromise where where there's some nights per week that you're hacking and sometimes, you know, but then if you're doing it like that, especially if you're like already hitting conflict with your partner, you just it's it really is a lot to ask to have, you know, a hobby that's so brain consuming.
So time consuming, right? This isn't like a cute video game. You can pause and like take a 30 minute break and then like go back to what you were doing. Right.
It is. It's it takes a lot of you away. So I would just be really respectful about it. And yeah, I think the more you haven't played like a marriage partner is different than a girlfriend and someone you have kids with is different than a marriage, just a marriage partner to it.
Like the more you haven't played the more complicated it becomes.
And all right. So now it's my turn to dig on you a little bit here. So,
so so one of the things I had on the list here that we have concreted and I think we do pretty well on now is the concept of me giving you my eyes when you do have conversations with me. Right. So, you know, she she tries to reduce the amount of times that, you know, that you're interrupting. Right.
And and when when you do come in the room, I try to I try to give you my eyes right away.
And I'm not I'm not staring at my computer. Yep. Yeah. Yeah. You can schedule that for Friday. You know, like that's a complex we had for the first.
Yeah. Is is you know, if she's giving me that that extra respect of, you know, holding off and that sort of thing, then I when she does come into the room, I give her my full attention and we we talk and we are efficient about it.
And then there's also just a level of connection there as well of like, you know, I know that it's a big thing for you to feel love that I'm looking at your eyes and I've given you my full attention. Right.
And actually, it's funny before this podcast, I was like, oh, you know, I hope we finish up the podcast in a good amount of time that we can go, you know, get coffee and stuff like that.
And she was like, well, you're going to be like staring at me the whole time and talking to me. So this is kind of like a date already.
It is kind of like a date. It is kind of like a date. And so I think I think that's probably more generally applicable.
I know that you get a little extra out of the eye contact thing, but I think that's probably generally applicable as well.
Um, I also want to add like back to the girlfriends supporting your partners, you know, if there is conflict, you know, maybe you've compromised.
You say like half the half the days a week or half the evenings a week. You can like take the whole evening and hack and I'll just do whatever else. Right.
I think our I don't know if it's our generation, our day and time and space. Right. I think it's really easy to be really dependent on your partner for most of your like social and mental needs.
Hmm. And I think, you know, there's a lot there's good stuff in that. But I think it's so important if your partner is a hacker and all of their attention is on this thing.
You've got to get hobbies, you know, like you have to have stuff in your life. You can't just watch TV every night that they're doing something that's really interesting and engaging to them.
One, it's going to make you a worse partner if you just they're doing nothing. And two, you're going to be so much less happy. Like get a hobby, get six hobbies, like get one for every night of the week.
Six hobbies. Get a book club, get something you like doing by yourself, get like a stand and coffee date. Like you don't have to sit home miserable all the time.
Cough, cough, play League of Legends.
League of Legends. That's a great one.
Don't just let yourself be bored and like waiting for your spouse to be done with the thing that they really like doing.
Yeah, that's a recipe for disaster. That's a disservice to both people in their relationship.
I agree. All right. We are we are an hour, hour and a half in, it looks like. And I don't have anything else. I don't think on my list. So, Mariah, thank you for stepping in today. And I love you so much.
I love you. And that was a great podcast.
And that's a wrap on this episode of Critical Thinking. Thanks so much for listening. And if you want more critical thinking content, head over to ctbb.show slash discord. Join the discord. There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there.
And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you access to masterclasses, AMAs, hack alongs, exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel with us. We'll see you there.